what I have here is a supply and demand
curve that represents that you could
view it as a model for the housing
market or the rental market in a given
City this vertical axis right here is
the dollars rent in terms of dollars per
square foot per month so if you have a
thousand square foot apartment and the
price were right over here that means
it's being charged a thousand the rent
for it is a thousand dollars per month
this axis right here is square feet per
month in terms in millions of square
feet so this is 1 million square feet 2
million square feet 3 million square
feet and so on and like we've done in
the last few videos when we've been
talking about consumer and producer
surplus I want to view the demand curve
right over here I want to view that as a
marginal benefit curve so for this first
the very first few square feet right
here how much benefit is it for the
renters the consumers well it's a huge
benefit for them it's worth over $4 per
square foot that's not necessarily what
they're going to pay for it but that's
what it's worth to them and I'm going to
view these the supply curve as a
marginal cost curve or the opportunity
cost for producing that extra
incremental unit so right down here when
we do have very few square feet maybe
the land is cheap or all the cheapest
land is available you just start or the
land that's most suitable for building
and so the cost the opportunity cost for
the suppliers of that those first few
square feet are very low and so it makes
sense that they will supply it because
they'll produce it their cost of
producing it is very low the benefit to
the consumers is very high so if the
price if the price is anywhere between
these two things the consumer will get
some surplus of the prices let's say
they're this consumer will get some
surplus and the producer will get some
surplus right over there and so the
market as a whole will be getting a ton
of surplus depending on how it is
divided now we haven't talked about
where that price is just yet although I
think you see where this is going so the
producers will keep producing more and
more units as long as the marginal
benefit is higher than the marginal cost
there is this surplus there that can be
divvied up between the consumers and
and the suppliers depending on where the
price is marginal benefit higher than
marginal cost marginal benefit higher
than marginal cost all the way up to
that point all the way until we get to
all the way until we get to three
million square feet per month after that
it doesn't make sense if so there's some
builder that says hey let me add some
more square feet to the market this is
what it cost them it's gonna cost them
over three dollars like well people
aren't even gonna get three dollars of
benefit from those incremental square
feet so no one's gonna get it so there's
no reason for anyone to build beyond
that point and so that's why this ends
up being the equilibrium quantity and
the price at which that happens the
price at which that happens and I rigged
this so we get nice clean numbers is
three dollars per square foot per month
now three dollars per square foot per
month is a pretty pricey rent if you
have a thousand square foot apartment a
thousand square foot that's my old
apartment that's like a two-bedroom
two-bath apartment that's roughly at
three thousand dollars a month for that
apartment so that's pretty pricey this
is the type of rent that you would see
in someplace like San Francisco and
let's say that the the the mayor does
not like this is this is unaffordable
people aren't able to live in our city
and so they they they Institute rent
control rent control which is
essentially a price ceiling they say
that the rent per square foot cannot be
above a certain amount that's not
normally how rent control is instituted
but just for the sake of our model let's
view it that way normally they say you
can't increase rent beyond a certain
amount but let's say that they say the
rent control they essentially put a
price ceiling on what rent can be
charged so they put a price ceiling a
price ceiling or a rent ceiling a price
ceiling at $2 per square foot per month
$2 per square foot square foot per month
so let's think about what's going to
happen and also let's think about what's
happening to the total surplus the
producer and the consumer surplus
so before well actually before we even
think about the rent control let's think
about what the total surplus is you had
the consumer surplus so if this is the
price right over here you had a consumer
surplus of this area right over here and
I don't know if this if this right over
here let's call this four and a half
if this is 4.5 then this side of the
triangle right over here is going to be
one point five that is 1.5 and then this
right over here is three million three
times 1.5 is four point five four point
five million and then we divide by two
that if you just multiply these you have
the area of the whole rectangle you
divide by two you get two point two five
million is that right yes 1.5 or times
one half of three that gives you two
point two five million million dollars
so in the equilibrium if you just let
the market be before the rent control at
this equilibrium price and equilibrium
quantity the consumer surplus is two
point two five million dollars that's
how much more benefit the consumers are
getting collectively versus what they
have to pay for living in that living in
those houses and then the producer
surplus the producer surplus is this
entire area right over here and if we
assume let's say that this right over
here I know it doesn't look like it but
to make the math easy let's say that
that is $0.50 let's say that is $0.50 so
this whole side right over here is going
to be two dollars fifty so this is going
to be two point five right over here
this length right over here is still
three so it's going to be two point five
times three times 1/2 two point five
times three would give you the area of
the whole rectangle you have to multiply
it by half to get the area of that
triangle so two times three so let me
just write this down so it's two point
five times three is that is seven point
five 25 times 3 is 75 and then 75 75
divided by 2 75 divided by 2 gets you
what it's 37 37 point 5 so this is going
to be three point seven three point
seven five so this the producer surplus
is 3.7 3.75 and since this is in
millions it's three point seven five
million dollars and so that's the total
value that the producers are getting
above and beyond their costs of
production and so the total surplus the
total benefit that the market as a whole
if you add the consumers and the
producers is 2.25 plus three point seven
five
so that gets us to what that gets us to
six million dollars of total surplus so
there are six million dollars six
million total total surplus so that's
good because it's we're at an efficient
price efficient clear equilibrium price
and production we're able to produce all
this total surplus now let's go back to
the rent control situation we're
instituting in instituting a price
ceiling of $2 per square foot so the
price is by government mandate being set
at $2 per square foot $2 per square foot
right over there
now if the price is set for $2 per
square foot what is the quantity is
going to be how much rent is going to
supply if they can only get $2 per
square foot maybe some of the landlord's
say you know I'll just break down this
wall and expand my own apartment or I'm
not going to rent these out as much or
maybe people who are renting out spare
bedrooms say oh I'm not going to rent
out those pair of bedrooms anymore I'm
just going to keep them as a guestroom
so the total quantity goes down the
total quantity goes down to 2 million
square feet a month now this is an
interesting situation because at 2
million square feet a month at 2 million
square feet a month the marginal benefit
the marginal benefit is much higher than
the marginal cost the marginal benefit
of an extra unit is over $3 the marginal
cost of an extra unit is right around $2
so in a in a in an open market an
efficient market in an unfettered market
people say well I'll just build more
units because people are gonna get
benefit from them and we can have a
price in between and we'll both be able
to experience some surplus but now you
won't even though there's this benefit
that's in excess of $3 because the price
can't be higher than $2 there's no
incentive for any of these people to
either build more units or maybe offer
the units that they have off up for sale
and actually maybe we shouldn't talk
about building this more long-run but
even the units that are there I won't
want to rent my guest room out because
I'm like oh it's too much of that you
know I'm not going to get my I'm not
going to get my marginal cost my
marginal cost here is over $2 and all
I'm allowed to get is $2 so I don't want
to offer that extra unit so what happens
in this situation when the price is set
right over here when the price is said
right over here the consumers
who happen to be able to rent at this
price who are able to get these first
two million square feet per month they
get an even larger for those those at
least for those two million square feet
they're consumer surplus is this thing
right over here is this thing right over
there and the producer surplus
unambiguously shrinks the producer
surplus is this stuff right over here
but you see that the total surplus is
now smaller than the total surplus was
when we had an unfettered market we no
longer are able to access this part
right over here of the surplus so this
right over here you could view this as
lost lost benefit to society benefit
above the cost this is lost surplus and
we call this in economic terms we call
this right over here the deadweight loss
the deadweight weight loss this is
benefit to the market that could have
gone to either the consumers or the
producers that somehow was taken away
from this market because this market was
made less efficient by this artificial
price ceiling right over here and you
can measure the deadweight loss at once
again it's only it's the area of this
triangle right over here and so if you
say if you say this right over here so
this this length right over here is
clearly just 1 that's 1 and if we say
that this height this height right over
here it looks like it is this is about 1
and 1/2 this is about 1 and 1/2 then the
area of this triangle this white
triangle right over here the deadweight
loss let me write it over here the
deadweight loss is going to be equal to
1 times 1.5 times 1.5 times 1/2 right
1.1 time 1 times 1.5 is double the area
of the triangle you multiply times 1/2
to get the area so that becomes 1/2
times 1.5 which is 0.75 so that gives us
a deadlock but it's point seven five
million so it's 750,000 dollars so this
area right over here $750,000 which is
lost to the market so now the total
surplus is going to be 750 thousand
dollars less than the six million
dollars so because of that rent control
it'll now go down to 500
five point two five million I took
750,000 out of this so it might have
benefited the renter's who happened to
who are able to get apartments it won't
be a benefit the renters who now that
they're not gonna be able to find an
apartment it unambiguously reduced the
producer surplus and it reduced a total
surplus the total amount of benefit that
the market as a whole was getting